all right miles i'll come to you first
right now so
your first big role on a tv show here uh
two-parter for you on that what is
something about hitting the set of the
wilds that just felt right that made you
think to yourself like yes i got this
and i am made for this but then on the
other hand what is something about
making a tv show that required a little
bit of a learning curve oh great
question um first part ivan is so
similar to me in so many ways we share a
lot of identities um a lot of
understandings about the world
unfortunately i am a theater kid and um
he is a playwright and
being able to step into a character that
felt so close to me and stood for so
much of what i have always wanted to
speak about and represent was the app
that felt very cosmic and universally
aligned um
a big challenge of stepping into a show
especially one as well oiled and
established as the wilds is that
the women really set the bar for season
one they really uh laid the groundwork
and let everyone know that they weren't
here to mess around and when you're
showing up to set with people that
already have these really deep
understandings of their characters
really deep understandings of how to
approach this kind of uh
physically challenging and emotionally
draining work um it's asking you to
really
bring your a-game and match everybody
and not to mention the physical
stressors of the beach and
the stamina that it required to shoot it
was um
it's a big show but it felt good to sink
my teeth into did you get the
opportunity to ask any of them for any
pointers whether it's shooting that more
physical material or just you know being
on location like that uh yeah absolutely
that uh girls are
my
dear friends and um i would i would ask
them for a lot of advice um
they often were like just stick to where
your character's at right now right in
this moment you can't really think up
too much about the big picture of the
show all you can really do is
step into those given circumstances
those stakes that you're presented and
tell that story as truthfully as
possible
and then the rest will figure itself out
it very much does all right nicholas so
for you you have a good deal of
experience but the wild seems like a
pretty unique production to me so even
with all that experience is there
anything about what it took to shoot
this show in particular that you know
really surprised you and maybe gave you
a new tool to put in your back pocket
and take on to a future project
of course um it's funny you say that a
lot of my previous work has been comedy
um you know i'm normally playing the
funny kid in the corner
so this show um was a challenge for me
in a really good way jumping into a show
that's more drama focused and telling
real stories
um so i found that
definitely a challenge and i was able to
honestly learn from people like miles
and the cast that were opposite from me
um they're all super super talented so
you know i
found that
quite fun and challenging and hard in
the best way yeah all right for the rest
of this i'm going to put up the spoiler
warning so do not worry we will not
release this and it will be properly
branded a spoiler conversation so no one
has anything written for them but i did
want to dig into what your characters
are going through here because
it's it's bold and it's especially well
done here so nicholas i'll start with
you
what kind of prep did you do personally
or maybe what did you need to talk
through most with sarah and the writers
in terms of you know mapping out the
different phases of josh's response to
what happens with seth because it's an
extremely complex storyline and it feels
to me at least like a lot to handle in
an ensemble show when you only have so
much screen time but like my god you
guys make the most of it yeah well i
think one of the
you say ensemble but we had so much time
in prep because this i feel like amy and
sarah really wanted to give us that
space to have a conversation about how
the scene was going to go and how we
could best tell that story so um
yeah there was a lot of prep we did we
met with them a bunch of times we
discussed it we met with the director
the dop we had the stunt person there to
make sure that i guess the mechanics of
the scene were all
good to go so that we could really focus
on
the the truth of the moment when we were
shooting the scene um
in regards to what it was like shooting
you know you do all this prep but even
when you show up on the night it's still
2 a.m it's still dark and windy and
you're still in this tiny tent
um and you really have to throw yourself
into that moment and it was quite
intimidating in a way because you're
kind of going in blind so um
one of the important things was the
trust that we had
we've been working with the crew for
months at that point so being able to
trust all of them um alex and i had a
lot of trust with each other in regards
to that scene
so i think
that all of that came into play when
telling the story and um you know after
seeing the final product it was um
[Music]
a relief to see that the story had come
across the way that everyone had planned
it was powerful and it was gut-wrenching
and you know i left feeling something
after watching it and i think
that it's a really important story to
tell i didn't expect any less after what
i saw them accomplish in season one of
the show but i feel like i was i was
very very impressed by how well that was
done and a very similar thing for you
too miles because
i i wanted to kind of dig into just his
evolution in terms of how he feels about
zero tolerance because like it's an
impres it's an incredibly complex
approach to a subject like that and it's
quite the thing to take on for your
first big project here so i guess like
what would you say were some of the most
valuable resources or techniques that
you came up with in order to prepare to
tackle each stage of that as the season
progressed
totally um cancel culture is so
complicated right um
ivan's relationship to online is a bit
different than mine um but we share a
lot of identities we share a lot of
understandings of the world and
understandings of ourself
um i think that ivan being so
uncomfortable
uh in this space adds to the stakes
constantly and that he's
those defense mechanisms and excuse me
those defense mechanisms and those
guards that he has up um are pushed to
the extreme more quickly than they would
be in another space especially since
he's around so many boys that
he wouldn't normally trust or want to be
around
so at the beginning it's uh it's a lot
about like
pushing that fight as soon as it feels
like it's coming up so that you give
yourself a sort of softer place to land
at the end of the season um yeah it's
very well done all right i think i can
squeeze in one more here just some some
playful predictions for the future but
you know now that we know at the end of
the season that the two ensembles are
coming together
which member of the dawn of eve
experiment do you think your character
would have the most to gain from if they
got the opportunity to spend more time
together and work together on this
such a good question um
i think for mine the answer is
maybe obvious maybe not but ivan and
fatin i think would just be
a stylish
funny and very intelligent duo um i
think they have a lot of brain power
that they could uh give to each other
i like that
i say
i think josh and
dot i think dot would have a lot to
teach josh i think in theory he
thinks that he could maybe survive an
island but she actually can so i think
he'd enjoy a lot having those
discussions with her about
how does this actually work like in
theory it should be this but she'd be
like no josh you you're gonna die if you
do that
i almost forgot asking that because now
i like want what you guys just said and
i don't want to put those expectations
on the writers but in them i trust two
seasons excellent now huge
congratulations on it
you